eu e as tecnologias não funcionamos isto
é página do facebook se montesquiou o
rosto tivessem suscitado e quisessem
falar da revolução francesa foi na
revolução francesa que nasceu a
liberdade ou pelo menos os conceitos de
liberdade pela primeira vez
liberdade igualdade e de fraternidade e
que ainda hoje 300 anos depois
constituem os fundamentos da nossa
democracia e da nossa cidadania
a fraternidade não foi muito longe
infelizmente porque o legislador nome de
um conteúdo jurídico e portanto temos o
livre arbítrio de sermos a não ser os
fraternos termos não termos abraços pra
sermos a não sermos capazes de chegar a
outro olhar para o outro como um igual
o que não está acontecendo a liberdade
foi um bocadinho mais longe mas tem
tantas restrições nós somos livres
porque achamos que somos iguais
esta noção de igualdade que nos dá uma
sensação
aliás esta noção de liberdade que que
não é totalmente credível porque estamos
sempre a ser limitados e por isso é na
maior parte dos países
ela é muito mais uma promessa do que uma
garantia mas a grande mentira de facto
tem a ver com igualdade
nós temos uma presunção de isla de
igualdade
nós somos iguais perante a lei nós somos
apenas iguais naquilo que diz respeito à
liberdade formal no século 21 não faz
sentido nenhum falarmos de pessoas
iguais nós não mexemos iguais à escola o
país ou nós temos a rua onde moramos o
bairro que vivemos os pais que temos
tudo isto faz com que o ambiente à
nascença que depois nos projeta para um
outros diz claridade os transportes do
tipo de educação à saúde que
eventualmente temos ou não faz com que o
estudo tudo isso se reflita na nossa
vida
não faz sentido no século 21 acharmos
que de facto todas as pessoas têm ou
acreditarmos que todas as pessoas têm os
mesmos direitos à nascença porque não
temos os mesmos direitos à nascença
ricos não são iguais aos pobres
o inteligente teens dos demais
o indivíduo que teve acesso à educação e
à cultura obviamente é completamente
diferente do indivíduo que é analfabeto
ao info excluído e isso faz toda a
diferença na vida adulta
há um estudo feito por acadêmicos
berkley de da universidade beckham e da
universidade harvard que dizem que 70
por cento das crianças filhas de
famílias pobres não atingem a classe
média na idade adulta estamos a falar
nos estados unidos
imagine o que acontece aqui quando 67
por cento da nossa população tem menos
de 35 anos e 10 37% e ficou com 2
dólares por dia
não temos todas as mesmas oportunidades
à nascença
o que acontece aqui a maior parte dos
países viveu até hoje confortavelmente
sentado nesta noção de igualdade formal
no entanto houve alguns países como é o
caso dos países nórdicos foram pra lá em
igualdade formal o que eles fizeram foi
materializar condições para que a
partida todos nós tenhamos a mexer sá as
mesmas oportunidades e isto é uma
garantia de igualdade
se eu for para mesmas papo uma escola de
igual qualidade que o menino que
eventualmente tenha nascido num bairro
pobre a partida na idade adulta nós
estaremos em condições iguais porque
tivemos acesso ao mesmo tipo de educação
com qualidade com a educação não se
brinca e eles foram muito mais longe
para além das garantias formais eles não
ficaram obviamente parados no tempo e
permitiram de facto que é é igualdade se
formalizasse fora entanto ele acha que
guarda que guardar 6 da formalidade e se
instalasse na vida no dia-a-dia das
pessoas e é por causa desta questão que
a democracia está a ser posta em causa
porque a democracia
o momento é apenas um apelo ao voto no
intervalo da democracia ninguém nos ouve
portanto eu do meu voto passa 14 a um
contrato tanto é eleições a quem nã o
precisa tomar um contrato que vai tenter
mim que sou eleitor e o proponente
candidato naquele caso o candidato eu
dou meu voto
ela sai do meu voto e eu nem o meu voto
porque eu acreditei na promessa que eu
não fez que iria cumprir nos próximos
quatro anos e o que acontece de facto é
que durante esses quatro anos eu deixo
de ser cidadão e passou a ser o
intervalo do voto e por isso mesmo em
todos os países a democracia está a ser
posta em causa por isso mesmo
na maior parte dos países do mundo a
abstenção eleitoral tem sido imensa
por isso mesmo as pessoas estão a deixar
de acreditar na política e
conseqüentemente estão a deixar de
acreditar né democracia mas é óbvio que
nós ainda não inventamos um outro modelo
político
até agora a democracia eventualmente é
aquela que é é forma - mar do júri a
maior parte dos países é aquela que
ainda nos permite acreditar que podemos
voltar a ser iguais podemos voltar a ser
livres e que de facto podemos construir
esta fraternidade e então onde está a
solução para a maior parte destes
problemas a escola que nós temos neste
momento vai dos é uma escola que vai dar
no sonho de estrear é uma forma escolas
tática é uma escola que não têm
conteúdos curiosidades que não têm
conteúdos de apelo de factos que
permitam que as crianças vão mais longe
é uma escola de massas é uma escola que
parte da produção que somos todos iguais
e aqui é pela negativa porque não somos
não estamos todos em igualdade de
circunstâncias de aprender ao mesmo
tempo as mesmas emoções e portanto estas
escolas tática o que está a fazer é se
thunder izar pessoas em diferentes anos
mudaram a mentalidade
mudaram os sistemas políticos mudaram as
nossas convicções e econômicas sociais
mudou a relação do mercado mudaram as
oportunidades de integração das mulheres
nós fomos capazes de construir uma série
de programas de ação social
construímos programa as bolsas de estudo
construímos programas de integração das
minorias mas ainda assim mudou tudo em
300 anos mas não mudou a escola
então o que nós precisamos de fazer de
facto para resgatar a democracia
o que acontece é que nós neste momento
temos uma geração que é digital que vive
num mundo onde as expectativas acontecem
ao 2º ea relação com a escola está se a
tornar com uma batalha
esta escola jurássica como eu digo é uma
escola que não não não apresenta
soluções para ocupar um momento presente
nós não podemos como estudar e lama nós
temos chances técnicos
onde estão as pessoas ficar para nós
gastarmos a democracia temos que
encontrar as pessoas nós temos que ser
capazes de olhar por outro que está ao
nosso lado e não ver um info excluídos
não ver uma minoria um representante da
minoria não ver portanto o o olhar pro
outro e ver um de nós no sentido dos
cidadãos
este problema é um problema que nos
afeta por exemplo em angola nós
deixarmos de ser cidadãos em angola nós
em golas somos primeiros sons do norte e
depois somos do sul
depois somos brancos e depois somos
pretos pois somos do petro e depois
somos do d'agosto e depois somos do mp
lá nós somos da unita e só no fim é que
somos angolanos
isto é um caso que acontece em alguns
outros países esta é a nossa realidade
mas acontece noutros países
então nós temos de facto que resgatar
esta componente da escola esta esta esta
possibilidade do desde os pequeninos com
luir é é tal igualdade mas baseada no
novo modelo a escola não pode ensinar só
matemática a escola não podem ensinar
português porque nós temos hoje nós
temos técnicos fantásticos a tecnologia
aumentou
nós vivemos num mundo tecnológico a
panela opção fala com o frigorífico um
show aspirador conversa com a televisão
mas não temos afeto
nós vivemos no facebook a maior parte de
nós ir lá mas não consegue ser irónica
fora então talvez por este é por esta
abordagem desta questão dos afectos por
esta questão como uma questão
prioritária porque o que vai acontecer
se nós continuarmos a educar crianças no
atual no deus juraci que a escola tem
nós não ensinamos art
não ensinamos a honra não ensinamos
fraternidade não ensinamos a defender
princípios não estimulamos as crianças
para curiosidade não conseguimos sequer
fazer com que as nossas crianças se
adaptem nós vivemos na globalização eu
não posso tirar 1 mil da xiv e mandou
todos bom conga
não posso tirar o indevida moimenta da
beira e mandá-lo para nova york
a escola tem que usar mecanismos para eu
poder esquecer a minha cidadania ou
outro estou falaram muito inglesa também
queremos transformar o que acontece é
que a nossa escola está a ficar
absolutamente domésticas
nós temos uma escola domésticas
enraizada desatualizada diz
contextualizada e que não tá em 3 para a
maior parte dos alunos
o meu filho mais velho que chama
frederico que vai fazer 16 anos está
naquela fase que deixou de ser criança
mas ainda não é dotar aquela coisa do
armário e no outro dia virou pra mim e
disse assim quando ele pergunta sobre
quando é que o que quer ser quando for
grande luta que as mães férias fazem até
que achei que tocou para o torto que
quer ser quando for grande e eu virou
pra mim e disse mas sim a mãe não
preocupe com isso a vida a uma seca
gasto de trabalho e mora pagava pra copa
isto porque porque de facto a escola não
mostra a outra parte da vida a vida de
facto não é isto eu não tenho que olhar
como o futuro a pensar que porque é tão
sombrio eu tenho que olhar para o futuro
e ser capaz como diz a facadas o jovem o
advogado que nos falou do crime temos
que ser capazes de viver com arte
mas isto ensina a capacidade de olhar
para a vida de uma outra forma não é
genética tem que ser ensinada isso tem
que ser ensinado por quem tem que ser
ensinado na escola o que o que eu
gostaria de deixar aqui como como como
para terminar é que de facto se nós não
conseguirmos mudar a escola não vamos
conseguir mudar as mentalidades e a
nossa cidadania está emprego da nossa
cidadania emprego obviamente estará à
nossa democracia emprego e enquanto não
formos capazes de inventar um novo deu
um novo sistema que eventualmente outros
países até já algumas abordagens mas que
a áfrica infelizmente continuamos a ir
atrás daquilo que são as democracias mas
depois dizemos que são as democracias
que me são impostas mas nós também não
tivemos capacidade de inventar outro
sistema
outro nível político
é facto só com esta abordagem com a
escola nova escola do século 21
falando de facto para que o modelo que
não lhes 30 já não não danifique a
criança o que nós estamos a fazer é
danificar as crianças não pensa x não
faças isso isso não é correto eo começar
a bloquear depois nós não compreendemos
porque de facto o desinteresse
relativamente a esta questão ea outra
questão é que os princípios da cidadania
têm obrigatoriamente que ser poste
dentro da escola é que o que eu queria
deixar comprou feição para terminar é
que a grande verdade é que estamos
exatamente no mesmo sítio onde estávamos
há 300 anos
obrigada
até